phénomène Harry Potter Harry Potter
Harry Potter les journaux télévisés
depuis 20 ans en juin 90 est le premier
tome de la saga Harry Potter depuis le
succès se déclinent en superlatif 7
livre 450 million d'exemplaires vendus
dans le monde 8 films qui ont rapporté
plus de 6 milliards d'euros sans compter
les produits dérivés et l'histoire n'est
pas fini avec Harry Potter tout est un
événement sortie d'un Tony sortie d'un
film souvenez-vous le premier volet de
la saga est sortis dans les salles
obscures en 2001 il y a tout juste 20
ans en France il avait fait presque le
million d'entrées
oui j'ai fini le quatrième vos lumières
il y a le film qui sort le 5 décembre
les livres ont été des succès les films
aussi
2 dollars de recettes pour chaque
épisode de la saga de la réussite
économique il y a l'amour inconditionnel
des fans pour leur héros les fans
d'Harry Potter un peu partout dans le
monde se sont retrouvés une est dans une
même ferveur et la magie de succès
réside peut-être dans le fait que les
enfants ont grandi avec un rythme un peu
en même temps que lui
le développement dans les nouvelles
matières enfin tout ce parcours j'ai un
peu avec la même chose que moi je peux
pas la magie grand-père il me disait que
c'était toujours un ami
[Musique]
évoluer tout comme le sorcier
alors quand en 2011 le dernier volet des
aventures d'Harry Potter débarquent au
cinéma c'est un mélange de tristesse et
de joie pour les fans
[Musique]
un grand moment
plus d'une décennie de notre vie et
c'est pas rien dans 6h c'est fini non
c'est pas fini
au cinéma mais il faudra pour l'instant
se contenter de l'épisode spécial sur la
plate-forme
prévu pour le 1er janvier
[Musique]